ici on propose des poupées qui ont
toutes le même point commun elles n'ont
pas de visage les yeux la bouche et le
nez ne sont pas dessinées
[Musique]
et pourquoi ils ont failli être parce
que normalement c'est me comparant
il vous êtes servent à fixer en fait
donc
votre avis il aime bien en posant la
question à non dans ma chienne poney
l'autre la souffrance
merci amin al baïd être avec nous jade
juriste en droit public hier on vous a
vu dans l'émission d'ailleurs on va voir
un extrait avec vous tout de suite ce
qu'on a pris des extraits avec amine
aussi bien sûr on va voir tout de suite
un des extraits d'hier soir et vous
merci d'être là et depuis votre passage
dans l'émission vous avez reçu
énormément de menaces certain nombre de
menaces quelques insultes dont soir
cyril merci merci d'être là de m'inviter
que menaces quelques insultes ça c'est
classique quand on prend la parole on
sait qu'on s'expose aussi à des
critiques à d un jeu aujourd'hui un cap
a été franchi évidemment il ya eu des
menaces de mort sur ma messagerie mais
ça n'empêchera et ça n'empêchera pas de
ça ne m'empêchera pas de d'agir de
continuer à prendre la parole et
d'essayer d'être mesuré sans stigmatiser
personne mais en pointant du doigt un
vrai sujet de société on regarde on a
regardé votre intervention lien j'ai
signalé cette association qui sous
prétexte de cours de soutien scolaire
effectué en réalité des cours coraniques
à des gamins âgés de 3 ans là c'est une
association qui gérait avec des fonds
publics dans des locaux qui
appartiennent à la ville de roubaix donc
c'est ce qui me gêne au fil des années
et discrètement l'association a hier
aurait ajouté à ses activités des cours
d'arabe
qui se serait transformé en cours de
religion amine a retrouvé des documents
qui étaient distribués aux enfants sur
les cahiers de textes des élèves on peut
lire révisé sourate al massad ou encore
apprendre sourate al fatiha donc
évidemment c'est pas des cours de langue
arabe on peut parfaitement apprendre
l'arabe cents à prendre à des enfants de
3 ans le coran alors c'est vrai qu'on a
de nombreux extraits vous montrez de ce
reportage amine el bahi
pourquoi c'est vous qui avez été qui
avait lancé la verte pourquoi m6 s'est
intéressé à la ville de roubaix c'est
c'est par vos tweets par vous évoquez
venons cadets ou pas du tout avec ce
truc que moi je suis très engagé à
l'échelle de la ville de roubaix je suis
juriste en droit public accord président
d'une association j'accompagne des
familles très pauvres dans la lutte
contre le non recours aux aides sociales
donc on va aider les familles on va les
sortir de la pauvreté et puis essayer de
les remettre à l'emploi c'est en
particulier les bénéficiaires du rsa que
j'accompagne au quotidien est ce que
vous avez pensé du reportage vous et moi
ce que ce que j'ai pensé du report ça il
y avait un stack boycott zone interdite
deux choses l'une la première c'est que
pour répondre à votre première question
je pense que la situation que nous
vivons aujourd'hui avec chemin c'est un
exemple cette association remet en cause
le travail quotidien qu'on que font les
acteurs associatifs dans la lutte
notamment contre la pauvreté ya eu un
appel vous avez raison un appel au
boycott pourquoi il ya eu cet appel au
boycott il faut l'entendre parce que
plusieurs de nos concitoyens musulmans
pensé qu'ils allaient être stigmatisés
et moi je ne stigmatise personne il faut
le dire il faut le rappeler
la quasi-totalité des musulmans de ce
pays respecte les lois de la république
de qui on parle on parle d'une minorité
une minorité de personnes qui ont décidé
d'imposer leur islam un islam absolument
pas compatible avec les valeurs de la
république et moi mon rôle dans cette
affaire ça a été de signaler un certain
nombre d'interrogations au maire de
roubaix qui n'a pas agi il est renvoyé
au tribunal correctionnel de lille pour
détournement de fonds publics par
négligence et mon second rôle sera était
de remonter cette affaire au préfet et
c'est le préfet qui a saisi la justice
on valoir un autre extrait qu'on voulait
montrer seront des coûts des sept écoles
dès l'âge de 9 ans les six ans
voilée séparées des garçons regarder ça
fait beaucoup parler ce texte
dès l'âge de 9 ans les filles sont
voilées et séparées des garçons signe
d'un islam rigoriste
cette enseignante l'assumé totalement
ils apprennent à vivre sont allés voir
le genre opposé mais non c'était même à
16 ans séparé ce danger pour plus tard
voilà parce qu'on nous donne des
convictions des valeurs et ses principes
et et l'enfance j'ai l'amour granger
avec est aussi compliqué pour vous donc
ram quelque chose qui est ils ont fait
flancher cours de sport cantine et même
lors des récréations les enfants ne se
mélangent pas cette petite fille
aimerait aller du côté des garçons mais
la surveillant clan n'empêche alors je
vais la nati ya plein de gens sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'on me dit c'est
pareil dans les écoles catholiques ou
les valeurs juives donc c'est vrai que
ça ça anormal de gens qui ont dit là
dessus voilà on est on est on est pas
d'accord sur cet extrait you pour moi
c'était un reportage complètement à
charge qui est basé entièrement pour moi
sur l'ambiguïté du mot islamisation plus
loin il ya une énorme différence entre
le fait que le nombre de musulmans en
france il peut peut-être progresser ce
qui est un fait et ce cliché un peu
islamophobe qui essayent de nous faire
peur en nous faisant croire que les
musulmans sont là pour tous nous
convertir à l'islam et nous remplacer
moyens dans ce reportage est juste eu
des gens qui pratiquent leur religion
librement et en aucun cas faire du
prosélytisme donc je pense que même la
manière dont s'est détournée dont
s'était montée c'est un reportage charme
répondait à sa mine
je pense que monsieur vous tenez le
discours que la gauche a toujours tenu
pendant 30 ans de notre pays et je pense
en second lieu que vous vous trompez que
vous faites cette image ici elles
concernent la ville de marseille mais
pas dans la ville de roubaix mais si ce
n'était pas pénalement répréhensible le
maire de roubaix ne seraient pas
renvoyés devant le tribunal
correctionnel
alors ailleurs parisienne ce que je
souhaite vous dire
qu'on pouvait pas dire y pratiquer
librement leur religion il appelle à se
séparer de la société française ils
veulent d'une part appelé un certain
nombre d'enfants adoptés d'autres
pratiques culturelles on a vu par
exemple avec des peluches c'est un
exemple parmi tant d'autres
ils ont des restaurants proposent de
regarder cet extrait de zone interdite
on apprend que des espaces dédiés pour
femmes voilées dans les restaurants
regardez ici les femmes voilées ou leur
place réserver
pour dîner sans avoir à porter le voile
il suffit pour cela de tirer le rideau
en fait amina tue aussi sur cette
extrême je me dis il s'adapte à la
clientèle sylla clients d une clientèle
qui veut qui veut que ça se passe comme
ça dans le restaurant pourquoi et quel
est le problème là dessus j'aimerais
savoir vraiment sûr sur ça
je vous renvoie la question une femme
qui va manger dans ce restaurant qui
décide de ne pas aller dans le box
comment il sera regardée mais chacun non
mais chacun fait ce qu'il veut s'il y en
a il y en a qui veulent aller dans le
box en a qui veulent qu'ils veulent pas
aller dans le mox est un essai il
s'adapte à clientèle les gens ont l'air
heureux dans ce restaurant ils sont
contents d'y aller par axa ça marche
très fort gilchrist a pensé de cet
extrait mais moi cet extrait il m'a pas
choqué non plus et j'ai trouvé qu'ils
avaient je vous dis toi même sur cet
extrait sur l'école je me sens c'est le
contraire même et d'ingénieurs de bien
vivre ensemble kiki moi que je pense
plutôt réjouissante je vais avoir des
mots forts là dessus parce que il ya des
très bons passages dans le documentaire
votre intervention est très pertinente
mais moi c'est la juxtaposition de tas
de choses on nous colle des tas de
choses dont lily regardez regardez moi
y'a plein d'excès ça y avait eu un truc
il y avait une musique de foix
rue de faudra maintenant dans un récent
oui mais voilà dans quelle mesure après
vos lagarde il ya un autre extrait
celui-là qui a fait énormément parler
aussi c'est ce témoignage d'un ancien
chauffeur de bus de la ratp il a perdu
son un peu curieux refusé de serrer la
main de ses collègues femmes regardent
ont fait elle arrive et même temps avant
jeudi bonjour eva vous ne seriez pas là
non non hervé moi je dis non et la mj
lorsque j'ai fait ma collègue
précédemment ces discriminations mbiwa
vous aurez un rapport par rapport à ça
j'aime écouter madame les chatons sera
pas là pour le contester si je vous
tends la main est-ce que vous l'apprenez
non je reprendrai pas parce que ma
culture dans les convictions religieuses
des femmes mais j'essayais oralement ça
c'est une marque de respect aux pas vous
serrer la main lorsque nous les femmes
on les considère comme des reines son
respect la gelée que ce soit seront
entreprises ou entre entreprises alors
il y avait cet extrait on verra vie sur
le restaurant qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous au tir à la ligne son
restaurant alors match sauf que dans le
d'abord je trouve que le reportage était
plutôt très intéressant et il y avait
quelque part en fait on alterne entre de
l'aide de l'inadmissible et de
l'admissible effectivement il ya des
choses qui m'ont paru plus anecdotique
et d'autres qui m'ont paru très très
grave